foreign
which we've never seen in any of these
films to introduce the maximals in this
film we thought the all in the beautiful
wonders of Peru would really captured
who the characters are
wow
we shot on top of Machu Picchu which has
never been shot before just thinking
about like wow one we're here but two
how did they make this this is insane
we are at the sanctuary on Machu Picchu
and we just had a shaman bless this film
and honor the people of Peru
it's a gift and we don't take it for
granted some of the challenges were the
altitude it would rain out of nowhere
and we had damn near zero equipment we
had to carry everything by hand because
we did not want to mess up anything you
could feel a different kind of energy at
Machu Picchu clouds will rushed through
the mountains it's just such a beautiful
experience
we shot in Cusco that was an actual
parade happening folks who were from
there gave it their all brings together
all the different regions in Peru so
each flow in each group in a parade had
their own Flair to it
and then shooting into Amazon jungle and
dealing with the elements
this mystical thing that Peru has
to get to do this project with the
people that I met here and it's gonna be
something that we cherish forever we
were doing something special yeah it was
magic